now I said I was going to show you two
things under this heading of compound
functions here's the first one when
you've got the original function of the
outside and universe function in the
middle the next one I'm going to reverse
things or should it pause for a second
have a thing what would you expect to
happen if you switch these guys around
have a think for instance about all of
the other kinds of functions in inverse
functions you already know about like
addition subtraction yeah I have
multiplication division logs and
Exponential's do you expect if you
change the order that you do things that
you'll get a different result so here's
what we're going to do these are
somewhat more involved so I'm not going
to go through one two three I'm just
going to do the first one and I hope
I'll be able to do it in a knot detail
that you'll be able to do this one and
this one y no se but i probably will
need to actually think quite carefully
about these ok because it's not as
simple all right let's do let's do sine
inverse of sine X ok
now you help us with this what I'd like
you to draw for me is rather than these
nice mini sized lines I'd like us to
draw two sets of axes that we can at
least go from negative 2 pi to 2 pi
because you're going to have to haul
copies of some different rest so I need
two of them and it's probably easier you
the one on top of the other so you'll
have a couple of wide graphs something
like this
mm-hmm
the reason we're doing these separately
is because you could do the one on top
of the other our Center gonna be related
but in the past when I have taught these
people just get really I get so confused
try to work out which one is which and
what am I doing here ya know getting a
lot of lines flying around now what
we're going to have is on the first
graph we're just going to do sine X ok
we'll have one copy going that way
another copy going this way from
negative tone part 2 pi to 2 pi and then
down here we will try and sort out
exactly what's going to happen when you
put these two together okay so draw me
the best sine X graph you can the more
accurate the bear so if you have a
template so everybody sound like a
broken record it's somewhat assisted
okay right so here's what we going to do
step two is with me I promise I'll go
through slowly enough but if you haven't
finished your graphing right now that's
okay i'm going to start with the easy
its first these events post okay and i'm
actually going to no shame in it i'm
going to good i'm going to step through
some values here okay so for starters if
i go sine inverse of sine let's just
start with some easy things how about
sign takes angles in right and in its
spits out a ratio what's up z not a
rhetorical argue it's 0 right
so then you say okay sine inverse i
might just draw myself a small one
demand you've already got this on your
page but i'm going to drop us off at a
small signing us curve yeah okay now
this graph says okay you give me a ratio
ratio 0 is not really a ratio and you
give me a value and i'll hand you back
the angle that comes with that okay so
sine inverse of 0 then is going to be
the angle to go through that the answer
is 0 right so I'm going to plop myself a
point let's try another ok sign your
verse of sign let's try say pie on four
okay now I know where pine for is here I
sorry that's apone two years planner for
ok so pilot for I just that's an exact
value sign up on for of course he is why
don't you help me out and on your sign
graph let's pop that up yeah okay
so you should be able to plot for
yourself by the way here's a way to test
how accurately you did your you know
your graph pylon for I know exactly
where that is with a great deal of
accuracy because going to be exactly
halfway between rotten pile to plan to
of course important because for the sine
graph what feature comes along it clown
to the stationary point the turning
point yes both of them okay so that's
good when I am map along to hear halfway
and then go up what is 1 over 2 you know
I know I want to do approximately is I
think it's 0.707 yeah so you should be
able to measure up and that should be
about like three quarters the way up
right which for me looks like I got
lucky okay so I just put i just put pine
and foreign to hear right then i get to
this part I'm now about to plot point on
to hear it's saying sine inverse of 102
sine inverse of 1 and reduce its asking
which angle in here in this range
which angle will give you a ratio of 102
the answer is payment for look here's
one so there's my ish one on route 2 so
that's a turtle scale you get the idea
be imagined ok so it's handing you back
plan for it's clearly i'm an acute angle
here ok so it hands you back when you
put in x equals plan for kids giving you
what it was playing for so far so good
so here's a point so if i call this
going down here if that's PI on for
their i'm going to go up the same about
ty on floor and there's bad your point
ok I could do this quite far but I'm
going to run just do one more point in
this sort of yeah i'm going to do pile
on through now and we'll do this a bit
quicker sign of play or to sign up il-21
society inverse of 1 which angle i take
a side of it will give me one of the
answer is papaya on to it's still within
my range so I hand it back right sine
inverse will only ever hand you back
angles within this range does that make
sense because that's that's what red
means so therefore what i put in high on
to why is also going to be able to hi to
that you can test this out obviously
with more points but clearly i'm getting
back like this is what i was predicting
f inverse of a function by definition is
supposed to hand me back a tax right do
my plots my points the implant look like
they're tracing out why it was out they
do good now i'm just going to take a bit
of a shortcut you can test it for
yourself if you like but this is going
to keep on going all the way to how far
can it go yeah negative pile too because
that's the furthest this range oops
that's the furthest this range will go
okay so i'm going to go ahead and
complete the y equals x line from
negative pi/2 to pi/2 let's just draw
down
okay so that was the easy part okay
looks just like y equals x now here is
where it gets really interesting and I'm
gonna show you put your pens down for a
second and just watch this work through
this with me like let's let's do it
matters ok I want to go past this domain
one of your passes to me I should be
able to because when we looked over here
right the domain restrictions were all
about these guys right there in between
negative 11 maybe 101 okay this guy's
weird but these are restrictions what
restriction is there on the domain of
sinx no restriction it just seemed just
go right as as you can see he'll keep on
waiting along as long as he likes so
therefore i should be able to put an
angle like say quite a bit let's try 3
PI on for now I want to try out 3.4
because I know exactly where it should
be on my graph here's pie on 2 and here
is high so where is 3 PI over 4 it's
exactly halfway in between them so
there's my 304 ok pens out of hand still
let's see how accurate our graphs all
right when i put in sign of three
platform where is it going to go
if my graph is decent it's going to come
to the same point right because site has
this beautiful century about it right so
sign free plan for is 102 so then this
guy says okay you put in this it's not
harm due to so sine inverse is ok sine
inverse of 1 enroute to what angle will
give me that ratio and the theta sine
inverse is will only ever hand you back
angles in here are three part 2 3.4
sorry is not in this range is it right
which angle is going to give that to you
we've already done this the answer is PI
on for so ok 3 PI over 4 you can pick up
a pen again now if you like to plot York
quite there when I ask it for x equals 3
phone for doesn't hang me back y equals
we plan for it cuts right 3.4 outside
the range of samos instead it hands back
that value there what's going on what's
it doing let's do one more okay I think
hopefully that'll be enough let's do x
equals PI X equal PI can we do that this
is really easy on our graph right
execute plan is right there okay so
therefore I should be able to say when x
equals pi sine of pi is 0 but at the
beginning the first point we plotted the
sine inverse of 0 which is ma'am now I
can keep on going
but I'm getting this where do you think
it will stop now then the easy way to
say is I know the range it's going to
stop that because the range has to
always stay between minus PI to impound
to write because that's all savior of us
will ever hand you you will only enhance
your angles within that range right so
I'm going to come down to wherever that
is yeah okay easy way to work out how
far it's gone it is look this function
it seems to be having copies of itself
right copies of itself from here to here
is how far how far is gone from minus
pi/2 to pi/2 that's PI unit right so
then to go down it's also going to go
play minutes so PI on to + pie I'm
expecting that's 3 PI 0 2 down there
then if you like go a few calculator and
put it inside inverse of sine we plan to
and it had better give you back minus
negative 1.57 bah-bah-bah-bah-bah ok now
we've drool the rest of this graph I
asked you to do so much of it so you can
actually test out these values over here
right for is this what's going to happen
if you put in a value like oh I don't
know this is negative PI over 2 right so
let's go negative PI on
for I know that's that's within the
domain I don't want that lets get
negative 3pi on fork what's it going to
do
what is sign of come on you can read it
off my graph right country is my
symmetry good enough yeah it's negative
102 right i'm picking all the same
points so when you go sine inverse of
that it asks ok what angle within this
range you give that to me and the answer
is not that guy that's outside my ring
it'll give me that this angle right so
that's why you're getting this bouncing
office ok and it's going back and forth
and it's periodic just like sign is
periodic how's my angel
okay now be really really careful we
look at these and we're like wow so I
would like so like right at really alike
but when you do coz inverse of cos and
tan inverse of 10 which you can either
number one do right now while your brain
is fresh in this this way we've thought
about it or you can wait until the
exercise hands it to you because it does
you will see they actually look
substantially different nice nice to go
to be bad in there but that's for
something okay